. Let's go next to Jacob from Nebraska.
Jacob from Nebraska, you're on the air.
Hello. Can you hear me? Yes, I
can. You do sound like you're under
underground, but I can hear you.
OK, good, good. I promise I'm not
underground. OK, as long as you're
not, it's fine to sound that way.
How are you doing? I'm doing well, thank you.
So I'm I'm from Nebraska
and the Nebraska Democratic Party is
notoriously bad at existing period.
OK, so how do how does the Democratic Party
kind of appeal and get beyond the social issues
that really hold the Nebraska people?
I think, in a place like Nebraska.
I don't think Democrats win by trying to convince
people on social issues. I think Democrats win,
particularly at the local level, by showing
how the last I mean, you could say 20,
30 or even 40 years of right wing
economics have economically ravaged many
Middle America states. I don't know enough about
Nebraska to know exactly what the source of some
of the economic strife is. But I would if I were
working in Nebraska as a Democratic activist,
I would I would figure that out and I would
focus almost exclusively on economic issues
and make the social issues secondary or
even tertiary to campaigns. I'm not saying
it would work, but that's how I would approach
Nebraska if I was trying to elect Democrats.
Awesome. Well, thank you so much. I've been
listening for a long time, been a member for a
long time. I really enjoy the show. So thank you.
Thank you so much very much. Appreciate the call.